again a trail
the kira soltanovich hey welcome to
another episode of the kira soltanovich
show i'm your host Kira and today I'm
very excited to have someone that I
remember from the early days of internet
cafes and open mics and just crazy
crappy shows back in probably ninety
nine maybe 98 mr. Hal sparks you folks
might know him from many things he he
was on talk soup for a while and he was
in spider-man 2 and queer as folk for a
long long time series regular on that
show and now lab rats lab rats is a fun
little show little Disney Disney show
for you um and a great comic I i
endorsed him on linkedin for improv we
talked about that we talked about
probably one of the most i don't know
how to label it Mikey Flynn what would
you label it like say a futurist yes
like a scientific podcast that I am it's
way above my pay grade I love the stuff
but I can't speak on it at all but I can
it's it's like my Russian language I
totally understand more of it than i can
speak but um he's fascinating and i just
love his take on parenting and comedy
and he's kind of like he's kind of like
one of those comics that's and this
isn't a good way this is not a criticism
but like a contrarian so like if you say
something about stand-up hit like now
that's not the case at all like he's
talking about like now I applause break
sir there's no place for applause breaks
in comedy things like that that just I
love to hear because i love i love
getting the other side of the story
because so many comics we're all a
little bit like broken records just had
the same over and over but not
how sparks so please enjoy this
hour and a half of how sparks oh yeah we
runs huh I know that you're a pro so
whatever you feel I don't need unless
we're taking calls I don't need can I
might call you Yeah right you already
called me a 27 year old king of
periscoping yeah we should periscope um
this podcast mm-hmm it's a great way to
what a Segway beautiful know it's so
professional are you on periscope so
yeah them to Twitter video thing no I'm
really trying to jumpstart my my youtube
channel so it does it that that to some
degree I think liquefies the brand a
little bit we're doing that yeah you
gotta have a consistent attack right
what if you're gonna do that then like I
think I think like Instagram like 10
second videos are okay but if you're
gonna try and video anything as a
consistent thing I think you know pick
if you're gonna do periscope don't do
YouTube you're gonna do don't do bears
well that's why I'm not really doing a
lot of Twitter because I want to build
my LinkedIn sure sure you know what I
mean kind of really bad up yes so that
people you want a lot of short messages
from people you used to go to high
school with writing you can get them a
job in a field they're not qualified for
right yeah it's a lot of like um it's a
lot of endorsing for skills yeah that's
so ridiculous and for abstract skills
it's not you know cuz ah you could be an
extra you could be a director you could
be a producer you could be a key grip
but you want me to endorse you for film
you know night right yeah what do you
all sudden like you did you you're an
extra on dude where's my car and I know
you from that suddenly you're ready to
be Citizen Kane you are officially Orson
Welles because I'm endorsing you for
film in or have you been endorsed for
like someone so is endorsing you for
your improv skills oh yes yeah I mean
anyone can endorse especially if it's an
ex-witch what they mean is liar yeah you
can make up a story in the
middle of nothing
his improv skills are great you should
see him when I find a text on its bone
yeah his excuses or any space work yeah
wait he's just trapped in a box are you
friends with your exes of course oh good
yeah all but like one maybe yeah yeah
we'll have that one sure you should yeah
uh all but one yeah it's good how long
you been with your wifey wife um I'm
we're not married but I've been with our
first night Sheamus seven years now is
it gonna gross you guys out if I take
this off I can't wait to hear what
people in the comments section below
please put what you think she's removing
in her giant boobied state so sorry I'm
so hot no oh god I'm so hot and I am
samples of that audio that's right so
Adam I take this off my god I am so hot
I wasn't listening cuz one of my nipples
fell out but um so you guys are not
married mm-hmm that's cool is that what
was what's what's the UH I mean I'm for
it yeah don't do marriage per se um I I
believe in long term commitment that's
not a problem okay um I just don't think
I need the state or a church to verify
it uh-huh I mean it's that simple and is
that something that um that uh cuz you
know people but probably know that you
are one of the sexy liberals it's true
yeah from the sexy liberal tour mmm very
little my sexiness very sexy um is that
is that where that comes from like
where's that or is it like no I mean I I
obviously gays destroyed the sanctity of
marriage and so I can't they destroyed a
lot of things that's what I go later
clearly I mean have a unicorn anymore is
it no cuz everybody just assumes I can't
so look if I want to wear a pink half
shirt and have a pocket poodle as a pet
I shouldn't have to answer all these
questions right well mall in Kansas
right I agree right no oh can we have
the rainbow back I think that I do think
there's an element of I don't wanna get
to brad pitt and angelina jolie you know
that's what I want I want I want a
you're right yeah my shirt off like
Waylon
um it's I I just think that you know
anybody saw my first specials Armageddon
I have a bit about marriage in that and
that it's really about property it's
about ownership of the woman even the
modern marriage how we do it is is a
faded you know film strip version of I'm
buying your daughter from you and we'll
give you four goats and the ring will
show how much money this family has and
she will produce male child like that
you know I'm offended by that Soviet
accent yeah I only did it for you okay
yeah under normal circumstances that's
where they Abrahamic traditions are from
and that's where our current confines of
marriage came from but the idea that um
you know marriage as an institution just
sounds like such a dick softener not I
mean is that something you also put in
your laundry huh dick softener softener
yeah okay I'm gonna find that a lot of
women put it in the laundry they don't
realize it yeah okay so that you when
you put your pants on you're not trying
to stop everything they know he makes it
it just sucks the life out of you Sally
how do you keep Frank on it monogamy
well same way I keep him bored in bed I
kill his sex drive I dick softener yeah
mmm summer breeze smell it smells like
my perfume right well you've been
wearing it for nine years I'm gonna
endorse you for improv after this thank
you but yeah I make most of my up
so you guys uhh you guys have a
five-year-old or four when kids are the
same age yeah um well here's our thing
our kids are from different
relationships she's got a 13 year old
I've got a four-year-old not from the
same right listen jerk but the
four-year-old you made with her nope no
boy he was a happy accident oh wait a
second I knew that hmm oh yes yes so
does he live with you part time the
whole time yeah part time part time
Justin yeah I see okay so I your baby
mama mm-hmm I know is that term indoors
term I would not endorse you baby mama
no we don't endorse leg linked to not a
fan of that word but did I praise the
guy head how do we sprays it then the
woman that you had your son with my
son's your son's mother that's it that's
it that's it okay I was trying to keep
it hid for the kiss yeah sure right I
was trying to keep it 2005 listening yes
can we go back and erase what I said
right uh yeah we're gonna take out some
of the dicks that we saw right Mike you
play um so you had a child with her but
were you guys in relationship no okay it
was just like hey guess what happens
yeah yeah biology had yeah right okay um
so but but and her 13 year old also part
time uh yeah it's less part time she was
married i poached her from that
relationship okay in matter of form uh
turist mean she is like it I'm not
completely capable of decimating a
marriage but you know if your foots
halfway out the door right I can work at
a tug on it yeah um um but you know I
was like she's a keeper so I'm gonna you
know extractor and where did you guys
meet in vegas doing a magic show
together stop it yeah no yeah the first
time I ever saw I didn't know you did
magic yeah the first time I ever saw her
I she was appearing in a fish tank yeah
she was working with a community with a
music magician named steve wyrick and
hear this trick and a lot of people done
it wherever you take two scarves two
handkerchiefs that are both red and you
pulled them out of your sleeves you do a
little magic trick then you go over to a
giant fish tank and you put them in and
you start waving your hands back and
forth and then they disappear and
there's a woman in a bikini that's the
same color suddenly appears in the water
it's a cool trick that's the first time
it's are in Vegas yep she's on stage
yeah you're in the audience yeah getting
ready to do a show there and what had no
idea you did magic yeah I did a show
called celebra Cadabra firs cadaver it
is the best worst name you could come up
with for this oh yeah who else was in it
who else was a celebrity down mm see
Thomas how aunt oh my god are you
kidding me this a show like just live or
was it televised was televised yeah yeah
it was it was a competition reality show
where you and because basically I I got
offered like competition reality shows
all the time why I only take because I'm
funny and interesting and I will do
anything so they don't like I'm kind of
fearless about that kind of stuff I
don't dive in and that's kind of hard to
find because quite frankly most of the
time when you're like oh we're voting
you off in the first two weeks is cuz
they quit like on those kind of shows
either win one golfer freaked out yet
yeah so I get asked to do them but I
only said yes if it's a skill I want to
learn or an experience and I'm you know
anyway like specific like I did
celebrity duets which was you know
actors you didn't know could sing
singing with real singers I do know that
I remember that I got to sing with
smokey robinson and Gladys Knight and
Dennis DeYoung from sticks and sebastian
bach and Dee Snider and who's a good
friend and has his own podcast just
throwing that out there I'm schneider
comments and it was one of those
situations and Little Richard and Kenny
Loggins in Richard Marx were on the show
and I was it was one of those things
were like if you passed up this
circumstance 15 20 30 years down the
road I like I had a chance to sing with
smokey robinson and I passed it up I'd
be a dumbass so no you can't you can't
pass that up and honestly the only
reality shows that I even have any
interest in are the ones where there's
some sort of skill yeah I love project
runway I want to see them build a dress
in 20 minutes right I designers today
you're going to make an outfit out of
the skin of a 15 year old girl escaping
the persecution of her parents welcome
to project runaway I see is that a bit
no it is now oh my god write it down and
joking about that bring you write it
down thats hilarious project runaway all
right get in the van Kentucky designers
the twist is you'll have to eat your
victims let's get started um so you know
I I do like those too I you know I hate
that they are artificially manufactured
cuz they throw this monkey wrench in
because people without skill so
misunderstand the actual skill that go
ahead that you can't just go on the pity
nuance of what actually is difficult
about the task you have to throw in some
radicchio
saying that like like Middle States you
know you know country folk who use
phrases like he's a hoot can understand
about Project Runway because they don't
understand is it yeah it's so funny to
me like my mom's friends I live in
Kentucky all watch project runway for
example but then spend the other half of
their time watching Fox News and and
complaining about the New York elite and
I'm like what the do you write
think a project these are people vying
to be a part of the New York elite you
so adamantly hate ninety percent gay row
totally yeah just man and women right
yeah and just so kind of forceful about
it so to me that's the that there's an
irony in that but I like watching the
thing in like that's why i like dirty
jobs or those kind of shows where i'm
like i don't see what really goes on and
you know you don't have to go PS you'll
have to do it blowing up balloons like
you know cacao off well I like
watching all those chopped shows like
anything cooking cuz again it's a skill
but the one show i don't watch is the
one show that you and I live I will not
watch last comic ya can't can't and
that's a skill it's a stupid but
it's a stupid show it's it's
ridiculous Last Comic Standing is a
fucked-up insult to the art of stand-up
comedy yeah and the shitheels who run it
hosted write it and make it happen uh
you know need to be set fire to other
than that I have no opinion about it I
understand why the comics that get on it
go on it sure Valley because in this day
and age yeah any level of promotion push
whatever helps right I don't know how
many friggin you know he came in third
on Last Comic Standing feature acts that
I've had you know open for me over the
years you know especially now but it's
stand-up comedy is not a time scale
teachable skill like that you know what
I mean cooking kinda is I mean you'll be
able to improvise you you can teach
somebody to manufacture cooking skills
in a shorter ones and also a taste not a
chef yeah a very short time if they say
spicy then we know what spicy means
right so if you're adding vanilla
extract you didn't add spicy therefore
we deduct five points whatever the thing
but with comedy it's so subjective until
personal I'm excited for the comics that
have gotten things out of it and road
work and and that's fantastic but the
process that they have to go through
it's the new you know what it is it's
the modern version of the 80s comedy
boom that it up for everybody to
the eighties comedy boom everybody
realized how much money you could make
on a comedy club is cheaper than bands
you didn't have to do you only dealt
with one member in bread of five and
let's make a comedy troupe most the time
it's just one guy it was way cheaper to
run it was a profit making machine
that's stds way less that's not been my
experience um but uh because I'm in a
band too right you are and there's a
difference between the two there's a
very distinct difference and I'll get to
that in a second but there was an 80s
comedy moment there's suddenly there's a
there's a club on every corner you know
for a while like every you know every
ten blocks in a major city there was a
comedy club or a comedy night at a club
and they ran out of real headliners to
fill the place so people who hadn't
reached the skill level we're suddenly
doing this and you get a lot of people
who have seven minutes or 20 minutes of
material suddenly doing 45 to an hour
right and and a lot of people leave the
club going I wasn't very good and it
came back right and it keeps them from
going to see the next person who might
actually have the skill right last comic
standing has a kind of same ramification
on the article ittle bit you know that
we saw one of the guys from Last Comic
Standing and he was okay just trying to
talk to the crowd great first ten
minutes yeah yeah or last ten minutes
you used his right he used the set we
saw on Last Comic Standing as his closer
right because he hasn't written anything
since yeah and then they won't go see
the next person who is a real touring
comic with a real act or a real you know
an actual chunk of joke so I'm hostile
to the entire show and I don't care who
knows it you know I it's it it glass
comic standing is to stand up what TMZ
is to acting you know what I mean it's a
peripheral at huh uh huh wow I gotta
look up adjunct can you write that down
Mikey Flynn all the words I got to look
up yeah I so comedy and met yes I will
say the difference yes there's a major
difference in the
rupees uh-huh and there are yeah um uh
in in stand up girls want you to be
their boyfriend okay in music girls want
to be your girlfriend okay what go slow
and stand up like there's math and girls
won't show your boy on the side what
yeah girls yet girls want you to be
their boyfriend okay and in music they
want to be your girlfriend okay it's a
very important all right light
distinction clarify please um it when
when a girl finds you cuz of your music
she's parading you as high his girl huh
ryan terry ownership and i see other
girls I see I'm his girlfriend got it
he's a thing and I'm his girlfriend
right when you're in stand up they want
the funny nice like hilarious guy they
can bring the family dinners ago oh my
comedian boyfriend is really funny and
interesting I see so I want him to be my
boyfriend because he's sensitive and
slightly broken but not so much so that
he's writing indie songs right and have
you dated both of those you have I've
had both experience and I've also had
the actor girlfriend situation as well
which is a totally different animal I
could never date an actor ever sure you
could no I've done it oh I did it again
you mean I could never do it again
judging us all based on all of you all
of you guys I'm judging your black
coffee without cream yeah that's the
first thing I judged you on mhm I mean
who how are you raised oh this is new oh
yeah yeah i see i blame the parenting oh
don't be drinking I don't know but cream
like an American OIC cream in your
coffee what's wrong with you do you like
a little cream in your coffee is a hater
look that's how I got into this special
everyday you got ah you have a
Frappuccino going on there's whipped
cream on that and sprinkles you know I
hate talking about my fat vagina but it
just happened a couple weeks ago oh it's
kind of extruding cuz it's starting
and your pelvis is shifting slightly
yeah you're ready for the baby to come
out so it hasn't exits don't care
doesn't bother me that male doesn't
doesn't he know what if it popped out no
okay it's not that it's nothing is
popping it's because there's weight put
on it yeah it's just sure ah it's a mess
here here's the good news okay after the
baby come right it will move back into
position well it did the first time
men's balls go south and stay that way
it's right what I mean thank you so much
balancing act made me feel always said
that balls at their best don't look as
good as a vagina at its worst and that's
kind of true you know what I mean oh my
gosh it's good you've really made me
think already in the first 10 minutes
what I'm here for that's all I do I love
listening to you on the radio yes how is
that going what's happening with that
got my semi regular Saturday show yeah
out of chicago w cpt radio is my main
station and it's on the i heart and all
that stuff now terrestrial radio is a
different animal than it was it's a
privately owned station which is great
because we can't be bought out or
over by clear channel with yeah what
happened to all the other progressives
in the country which just hurt me yeah
on such a cellular level I was so angry
glenn beck and limb bar on in LA in san
francisco now cuz 11-50 yeah which i
listened to every morning yeah and i
have sirius and XM in my car and of
course we have podcasts and we have our
phones that have anything you want but i
would listen every morning right and
then it just all got up yeah and
it's a shame where we don't have any
progressive radio in la anymore yeah
it's it's ridiculous so um how long were
you on there with Stephanie um four
years for so it was you Stephanie John
Fugelsang yeah and sometimes Rick
Overton yeah I started doing Wednesday's
it became hump days with Hal right that
was my suggestion that came because
literally I was booked by a stand-up gig
I was doing like I think flappers it
just opened or something like that I was
doing a gig at a real one nite at The
Improv and there ironically enough in
this city in la there is no press to do
to promote
no I mean really yeah I mean think of it
what is their ktla morning news and
that's it like in if you if you know i
did kevin and beans in my special and i
did Heidi and Frank but that were your
special not a show show right right
right i mean like you go do stand-up in
another city right you're doing it
you'll be every radio oh yeah every you
know the local TV twice that day on
friday have you ever done those cities
where it's like the country station
wants to the wrestling station why do
they all want to promote yes I feel time
yeah yeah and la there's none of that
plus everything's free so everybody
takes it for granted it's like it it's
like la is a complete city full of
teenagers who download their favorite
artists and then wonder why they're
artists are going broke or can't put out
albums right yes PS you um and and
so nobody shows up to a gate I mean you
have to promote so much harder in LA to
get people to show up so there was
nothing so I listened to stephs show a
lot every day so I was like she's here
why don't I call into her show and
promote a local you know gig I'm sure I
couldn't manage to do and she said I
think but grudgingly okay mainly because
of queer as folk and this was she was
still in the closet at the time and
crisil boy her producers out and gay and
knew of it and spoke very highly of the
show so I think that was mainly how I
ended up so I'm on hold and I think they
forgot about me and I was on hold for a
good 20 30 minutes and it was just when
the Affordable Care Act was being
debated in Congress mhm and everybody
was going on nobody has read this
remember the wagging about of the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare and
nobody's read this well I'd read it and
I read it the whole thing cover to cover
because I was so annoyed that everyone
was saying no one has read this you know
I was like okay i'll i'll read it you
read it in the time they had you on hold
no no I read it I dread it weeks before
okay uh but I could have reread it in
that amount of time skimmed um but the
the reality was is that you know any
time a bill when somebody goes nobody's
read this there are committees that have
actually gone through every single
segment of it and have okay talk to
their caucus gone back and done that
nobody reads the bill cover to cover
because they shouldn't have to they got
representatives in their own caucuses
both Republican and Democrat they go
through the whole thing and break it
down and then explain to their their
group what they want to get fixed and
what they don't and go back and forth so
the idea that it's it's all
there they know exactly what the
in it that same thing about defense
appropriation bills are larger than the
ACA they sign one every year it happens
it's all gone through committee so this
it's a lie whenever they say no one's
read this they're full of but I
read it because I was mad come on hold
and I'm listening to Republicans calling
in going it's the end of America and
liberals calling in going we need
single-payer and this is and
and I was both of them were wrong about
what was in it none of them were no one
knew where they were talking about so
when I went on I didn't end up promoting
my gig at all end up speaking for like
20 minutes on what was actually in the
Affordable Care Act and what it would
and that I actually think it is a
precursor to single player which it is
and it's it's like that you know and
that's why the Republicans were freaking
out not because what was in it but what
cuz it would write it would trigger
right and so they asked me to come back
and talk about it the next week and then
it became a semi-regular thing and then
we started calling hump days without and
then I started coming into studio right
I do the whole hour and then you take
over sometimes yeah out filling if she
was out of town right all right and um
did Stephanie always do stand-up cuz you
guys snow came out with that not really
sexy liberal yes I thought was genius
yeah she was kind of she kind of did it
Karen Carpenter storytellers scholars
you have a music stand and her jokes
written on there and she kind of talk
openly is a little more her speech she
did stand-up back in the day but kind of
the same way that like Paul Rodriguez
did stand-up back in the day Paul
Rodriguez start doing stand-up because
they were looking for a lead in the
series AKA Pablo and they wanted to
stand up but there weren't that many
Hispanic stand-ups at the time so
apparently he went and just bought a
bunch of jokes that would fit whatever
rehearsed him like a monologue and did
stand up and then had the casting people
come see him and then all the sudden
Paul Rodriguez is a stand-up and he's
got a guy that thing and he's you know
he's very good at it but he it took him
a long time to catch up right the
perceived level interest he went to his
own Last Comic Standing kind of right
period right right you know here he is
doing comic relief cuz he's in this
series and you know as a narrow field
and when you started you didn't have
your kid yet started on no on the radio
no no no this is a while ago yeah yeah
yeah and were you always so liberal like
were you always progressive did you do
political stuff in your stand-up I
remember you it's hard in LA like when
you start mm-hmm um to like who's in
your like comedy class so to speak my
class system but like almost like you're
graduating class yeah sure and I just
think like well who was around when I
was doing the shittiest gig yeah cuz I
feel like that's where you have to start
from yeah and we were doing like a lot
of just cafes and buy a croissant to get
stage time oh shitty gigs and I don't
remember you being you know political at
all well my stuff even my modern
stand-up isn't political its
socio-political because I actually
believe you can't affect mental change
through political comedy directly I
think you end up preaching to the choir
and alienating part of that so I was
gonna ask you what kind of crowds came
out everyone that's just like we agree
yeah right well we had some Republicans
come out to Gay like we got picketed we
got a fire alarm you know called in on
one of our gigs in Boston because we had
to be out of there at a certain time in
this particular theater and they knew it
so they could cost us twenty thousand
dollars by making us go over if they
called the fire department on us that
kind of stuff like it all kinds of
shenanigans that being said I don't my
stand-up at the sexy liberal show was
completely different from my regular
stand up and then it was a hundred
percent topical there I did like cuz i
was like political stuff and then any
what's going on yeah the way the
presidential race line improv but you
know i write jokes and I craft jokes but
I but those particular shows i was like
this has to be ripped from the headlines
stuff and but I go out free wheeling it
i don't have notes or anything like that
i just have to go I get it's a 20 minute
25 minutes set yeah and so I just
bulldoze um and so what I do is I try to
come up with like 35 minutes worth of
material stuff that I want to talk about
from that week okay and then I kind of
listed in my head and then I bulldoze in
but back to my stand-up not being
political my standard was incredibly
pull it
Cole I just don't use the buzz words
because it shuts your brain down one of
the things like Frazier as I had no I
had an overt what's called was the
product we called o Dick's office
exactly right it's a dick softener um
during the bush years there were a
couple of times where I just had
it you know and I on stage I kind of
needed to go after this cut and I really
had to call him you know out bush and I
realized that by doing that I was the
people that I was very much trying to
reach their ears closed like
doors on the Death Star I mean they're
not here and it wasn't because they
wouldn't agree with me it was because if
you joke about the president the
terrorists win you say Bush is a you
know you know and Cheney are dangerous
war mongers the terrorists win and I
understand that fear and I understand
what they were going through so I was
like how do I reshape what I'm saying so
that it gets in past the critical
security guard that is guarding their
subconscious you know so I instead of
that's where I actually wrote a bit
about how do you do that well I like I
started by writing bits about guys in
cowboy hats who don't have any cows you
know that guys it's an hat you
know what I mean he's he's selling you
something you know what I mean there's
only there's only one kind of guy who
wears a cowboy hat and doesn't have cows
and he's a car salesman and he's trying
to you and that was it and I never
mentioned bush in the whole thing but I
created this kind of hey man podunk II
kind of dude that you'd have to be a
total dunce to not know that I was
talking about Bush and his brush
clearing crap that he was always doing
but what it did was laid the seeds for
the next time you saw him talking and he
was wearing his dumbass cowboy hat
selling even though it there from
Connecticut selling this Texas lifestyle
you know veneer you couldn't absorb it
the same way uh-huh i mean that's smart
and um so one of the ways you can
promote gay marriage for example i
believe is by undercutting the value of
marriage overall aha because the certain
people who don't want gays to get
married
if you lessen their attachment to it as
a religious thing and more is an
institutional mechanical tribal thing
which is exactly what it is their grip
on Jesus hates it if this happens kind
of loosens a little bit okay not that
I'm really going to undercut the value
of marriage but I'm loosening the
particular latch point that they have on
the ideology that just seems so
impossible to do in this country not
it's not super easy is it yeah it that's
what I mean it's not your ice skating
uphill if you're trying to overtly like
my I just did a little thing in my
youtube channel about with Marc Savard
he's a comedy hypnotist who also does
like hypnotherapy and I went to him last
year and just to remove some blocks that
I her subconscious that I have clearly
that we all have right I was just like
cleans it and I was like I I've tried
every possible methodology over the
years to kind of get rid of these
roadblocks I'd set in my own way how do
I do it how do I get past them and it he
said something really smart which was
you're trying to fix something
subconscious that on a via a conscious
level okay so you have to fix it
subconscious yeah and so if you overtly
attack it overtly go after it you're
never gonna do it it's like and the
analogy I came up with while we were
talking was it's like trying to fix the
rudder or the propeller on a ship
without ever getting wet uh-huh you're
trying to stay above the water right
we're fixing it and sorry in in in doing
real and doing real societal change with
your stand-up you have to go about it
under the radar to the point where
you're not getting applause first of all
I think applause in a stand-up setting
is a terrible circumstance what like
they got applauded the show not making
sounds during sex no no no no laughter
is what we're after not applause I
applaud during sex well I've had that
happen to me but I've never done it
myself um we're gonna plot it yourself
yeah I like your site all three
okay sparks mm-hmm sip break I love that
you think I'm kidding oh come on yeah
how many threesomes have you had that's
a that would be a foursome what none of
your business or so tell you that's
right no longer on a Disney show oh
you're on Disney show right now all
right so so you can only have like
twosomes yeah it's got it the
old-fashioned old American one on my
twosome Kwazii monogamous sex got it
yeah we're monogamous now we just were
uh we're technically polygamous but we
do it in a line we're monogamous one at
a time in this society everybody has an
ex right nobody's monogamous anymore
Monagas meant one person that's it I see
for an hour I'm monogamous with this
person then when it doesn't work out
I'll be monogamous with the next person
you know it'sit's chain-link monogamy um
is what we practiced these days that
being said I I just think I named my
special charm again because I realized
that I was able to wreck people's social
and political and psychological concepts
and still have them like me uh-huh that
was the goal that they come away going I
like him even though I totally disagree
with him many he destroyed my ideas on
marriage on religion on you know it's
you know social arcs or whatever right I
want to come away with you know I want
it to be a positive experience because
in comedy laughter is the first job a
lot of things I think a lot of comics
mistake either meaning or impact for the
first job it is right laughter is always
the first job yes the nature of the
child is you're a philosopher right to
end up philosopher Oh a artist
anybody anybody anybody history the
world part one yep um so I realized that
if I really wanted to make a political
impact um I you know I had to be covert
about it I had to sneak it into your
head right because that's what comedy is
it's neat
change into your head it's not over it's
not a bumper sticker on the back of your
Volvo it's a joke and a
well-crafted joke that makes you go oh
right bra I am full of on that
level or I am doing something stupid
repeatedly that i don't like or don't
want to do or don't agree with did you
grow up in Kentucky as a democratic your
family Democrats yeah they are yeah yeah
I just don't see that being viable
incoming that unfortunately the concept
of what is the southern gentleman is now
dead because it used to be that a
Southern gentleman was actually a highly
educated human being well-read
well-thought-out time Jefferson would
qualify as a country gentleman right
right dates businesses intelligent
having sex with his slaves
notwithstanding oh well read human being
who read the Bible in the Quran you know
did his own edit on the Bible took all
the miracles out because he thought it
was that was you know extravagant
added by the writers at a later
date which is you should be the actual
name of the Bible extravagant
added at a later date yeah but so you
grew up you grew up pretty liberal sure
okay I thought maybe this this was new
known for some reason no no this is like
from childhood this is your parents
pretty liberal uh this is just me yeah I
just didn't I mean I'm surrounded by
racism and sexism and homophobia and all
that kind of stuff well that's because a
you live on the west side huh all right
uh but in Kentucky for sure you know
like I have a joke in my act right now I
talk about learning to drive which is a
almost 40 minute single bit Wow to one
bit that's impressive um I'm already
jealous and it's based on a concept i
learned from listening to woody allen
talk about comedy which is write a joke
that you really like and then get as far
away from it as you can and try to get
there back away to buckle well ok give
me an example um like he was talking
about his joke was every time he uh he's
in his apartment building in New York
every time if he's taking a shower if
anyone in the tri-state area flushes
their toilet he gets
skull right I joke okay it was a
relatable joke but a single joke but not
that big he gets to that joke by
starting with his know I've got my first
apartment you know after leaving college
but my parents did you know raised us in
a closet lower east side you know under
some clothing of a you know the local
rabbi you know we lived in a pocket and
the point being is it he got all the way
back to his childhood right and got a
run at that joke that joke is not that
great standing by itself but with a
lineage wow I've always had the dream
you know of having my own a pun yeah
that kind of idea then when you get to
his dream has come true and then the
same happens to him that happens to
all of us right suddenly that joke is
gigantic interesting but in the in the
context of that I talked about you know
local drivers in whatever market I'm in
and to lead in into that and I get as
far away there and I go back to when i
learned to drive and i learned to drive
when i was 13 years old and the context
of telling a story i talked about how
when i was six years old I learned I I
grew up I was lucky enough to knock her
off racist in an area that was at the
time especially very racist and there
were these three old rednecks that used
to hang out in front of our general
store that were you know I have to thank
for that and it's not because I wasn't
they weren't racist they they were they
were horribly racist but their accents
were so heavy I didn't understand the
derogatory term for black people that
they were using I thought they were
saying nickel when I was five years old
I had never a nickel nickel travel well
knuckle down all the nickels nickels and
you know I was like and it bugged my
braid it cuz the seeds fell on sand my
brain rejected it cuz I was like what
the are you talking about nickel
what do you mean girls are annoying but
because they're bigger than dimes but
they're worth less yes it's but at the
same time I was I literally at find this
is true story at five years old I was
like why wouldn't they call them pennies
because it's you know it's the lowest
denomination of coin you don't think
very highly of them so that makes sense
it's
Lincoln on it you hate him and
it's the only coin of color I was five
and I figured that out so this bug me
but that was why I didn't grow up with
that term embedded in its ok to use it
uh-huh because my logic rejected it next
time I see a black person I'm like
nickel please right that's right now you
that can I hey okay let me know how that
works out you're pregnant so you should
be fine for a little while um but that
that's true without that's about getting
as far back from a joke that would have
a level of commonality about it and
getting a run at it I have literally
done a version of the learning to drive
bit where I've run out of show I've not
actually gotten to my set looking at the
light and you still haven't gotten to
the big time sir I haven't started what
the material for the rest of the stuff I
was gonna do that bit gets so stretched
out and has so many laughs in it and has
so many jokes just I'm crow barring them
in right fast as I can right I want I
love jokes you miss yeah I like ripple
laughs I like the joke and then two
jokes later you're like oh what the
did he just say you know me and you get
the comedy echo which is like he said
his mother but doing it right business
that means Jews are in the audience uh
excuse me uh Jews do not have not
cornered the market on that Jews are
constantly repeating jokes louder to
someone else or southern people whose
the same look I got news for you all the
followers of the Abrahamic traditions
Jews Muslims and Christians are the same
people come on all the same come
on one point in society Jews had
cornered the market as immigrants who
are outcasts who were vital society to
society but not actually integrated now
those are all in my wedding vows what
you just said exactly uh no longer true
what no longer true not no not in an
intrinsic sense nope not on that level I
mean yeah we still have high anxiety the
movie no is the trait
do you still own criticism God don't
know that away those Catholics have it
too and they fell the iris part Irish
have it the Irish in and and jewish
sensibility is almost identical and
especially during a period in American
history where they were they shared
almost the same societal traits as far
as acceptance and non-acceptance in
society I would much rather have an
Irish nose all right don't give me this
this is a load you have a Russian knows
anyways yeah so I'm saying mia has
nothing to do with Judaism is tons of
austell you don't think this is anything
to do Judaism this is not a Dubliners
first of all I have been to all over
China and there are his there are
Orthodox Chinese Jews yes there are
which is end of conversation behind
blowing wind why those people are just
those they are lost how did that even
happen says a woman about members of her
own religion ah i am so you don't have a
religion right you're not religious i
want i want to talk about no i don't i
don't actually think God can fit in the
human corpus callosum I don't think it
it makes it impossible that it exists
I'm what I call a power agnostic but um
so how you're raising your kid huh cuz
it sounds I'm is raising my son to to
worship Crom the ghost Conan if you want
to know what my idea of fatherhood I do
it's why you're here watch watch conan
the barbarian okay and the opening
monologue where his father is explaining
the god they worship them in the riddle
of steel to his son who sits there
pleased but dumbfounded at his barbarian
father explaining to him but your kids
for so as he started to ask about stuff
no because my kid just my kids four and
a half he just started to ask about um
where my grandmother is who by the way
lived to 101 so I told him that that's a
pretty cool thing i said but now she's
she's not here we can't like physically
see her but I feel her and I'm
trying to get esoteric with him I don't
know where to draw the line oh and he
goes so what do you mean she died and i
said well yes no physical expression of
spiritual being is a temporary thing and
it is becoming that temporary period is
becoming longer he lost his mind hmm he
started crying so hard he said does that
mean you're gonna die one day and I was
like we are sitting in the target
parking lot this is not the place for
this at all right but as you know
there's never a place so I just I was
good question I was looking at him
through the rearview mirror cuz i was
looking for a parking spot and uh and i
said well you know that's i just kept
saying over and over again we're humans
so that's what humans do you know that's
eventually news is you're gonna live a
lot longer than Nana or whatever right
and he said does that mean I'm gonna die
he cried alligator gee I've never seen
him cry so hard in my life I said you
don't have to worry about that right now
we're just going in to get paper towels
at target like please what's going on
was Robert he's not upset that he's
gonna die it's that he's wasting his
time getting paper towels at
target if he knows he's limited cuz
that's what you're crying about you're
not really crying that you're gonna die
i also bought him a toy because i felt
so bad yeah nobody nobody cries
about what they're gonna die they cry
over the wasted time and the things are
gonna miss but why not gonna miss
getting paper towels at target what are
you what are you teaching your cake I
mean can you teach your kid at four no
um Frank it they can't handle hell no no
no no and it is perfectly well you can
teach him to be a liberal sure I teach
my kid that sometimes I tell you need
our kind yeah the liberal thing falls
out of that naturally right but I you
know what like we talked about sometimes
people don't have a place to live sure
so what do you say when your kid says
why not do you say because president
bush it up everybody no I Reagan
I go all we reckon Reagan you take the
joke all the way back like Woody Allen
wave far away economics and um
uh
well I make the case that there's a lot
of reasons there's a lot of reasons why
people end up without a house to live in
or an apartment to live in and we have
to do our best to make sure that we can
be as helpful as we can to help anybody
who's in that situation yeah find one
right and so whatever we can do if you
can think of something that will help
them you tell me and we'll we'll do it
and if you can't we'll just do what we
can do which if you want we can go help
feed some people yeah we can help when
you get older we can go help build a
house for people to live in and we can
do our part together will do Habitat for
Humanity he can you know once he's ten
years old or so yeah he can come help us
build a house we once gave a homeless
person at the end of an off ramp we had
two bananas mm-hmm you know in the front
seat with me and I said hey you know
what there's a guy here who looks hungry
and I'm reading his sign that says he's
hungry can we give him one of our
bananas and my kids said okay and then I
gave him a banana and then right as we
drove off he just freaked out he was
like that was gonna be my banana I said
we have one here uh-huh we had to do you
can't no no and he lost his mind and I'm
worried first of all he didn't lose his
mind he never had his mind don't confuse
children with adults is a dickish thing
to do okay but understand kids okay his
entire prefrontal cortex yeah is gelatin
right now okay is he does not have a
moral compass nor should he because it's
dangerous for him if he was left on his
own he would have to scrounge and you
can't scrounge if you're like does
everybody have enough quick he right he
his prefrontal cortex will not be fully
formed until he's 22 years old
so you're arguing with someone who is
mentally deranged up to that point to
some degree to a lesser and less degree
hey you're ready 4 5 6 10 12 years too
old they have different strategies to
make sure their brain grows you can
guide it like a bonsai tree but you're
not going to change the nature of the
tree itself
okay and so what you try to do is try to
sculpt that tree in a direction and part
of it the way you do that is by not
freaking out and clipping the branch
that just grew by going with it why
don't you understand it's like you have
to we get two bananas like you
can't do that with him because his
brains not gonna you're absolutely right
I don't know why in the moment I forget
that there's a there's a very famous
comedian who's doing very well these
days so the you know it's not my place
to necessary to tell him how to do his
business but on a philosophical nature I
disagree oh the basic premise is that he
goes I think the joke is if four people
are trying to leave the house and one of
the people is holding everybody up
because they won't put their shoes on
that person is an right if
they're adults I agree but you can't
overlay the psychology of an adult onto
a child or you're the aha you're
really if you're expecting and I
know my joke I hey yeah like an adult
you're an this child can't Oh
behave like an adult or it will die if
it's left on its own okay so let me ask
you this because I have this
conversation with my husband a lot mhm
he tries to uh you know um like you know
with what's the square peg round hole
like huh the four-year-old into an adult
yeah I mean that sounded weird and into
adult hole I'm so sorry I apologize but
you know what I mean he's all about the
Duggars but I constantly have this
conversation with with Mike and I he his
theory and a lot of people would say
this is that well if we just let him
behave like a four-year-old then he'll
get spoiled and I'm not saying you don't
correct them right you do gentle
correction understanding that they don't
understand you you have to come at it
from the perspective that parenting is
hard yeah um you have to come at it from
the perspective of this I'm not talking
to the same kind of brain I have it
doesn't operate on the same New York
thing the same even even that's why they
say magical things every so often where
they go oh my kid just said
something really profound right that's
because three weeks ago you said
something that they totally did not get
but synapses have formed since then
Brian your brain material has grown into
place and is making a synaptic
connection that it was not capable of
making even two weeks ago and it's gone
oh I get what you were saying it
literally bumped around and it's
cul-de-sac looking for something to do
yeah so my you know I I gently and
sometimes firmly correct my son like
give me an example um okay so very
seldom does my son talk back to me for
his own choice I've never I don't hit
him I don't spank him I don't believe in
corporal punishment at all but there's a
dad severity I apparently have that he
gets he gets and it might be from the
fact that if he wants to be put down I'm
strong enough to keep holding him the
entire time with eating kick and scream
but I'm not he's not gonna flop all over
the place I'm you know I'm strong enough
to go you're not going anywhere if you
want to get down you say down please
wake up trained him in that regard just
say down please and we'll put you down
stay down please and ago that all he
wants until he says down please and then
once he does he gets it okay and then
he's following an order based on what he
wants and communication not because I
want him to be wrong but because he
needs to communicate what he needs
better and that's what that's why
they're frustrated in the first way so
but sometimes because of their things
that happen in his other household he
either in this is because part of his
life is opaque to me I don't have a
relationship with his mom and what goes
on in their household he can get a
little mouthy with females and I don't
like that so I don't allow for that so
he does that with my mom or any other
female he starts getting belligerent I
have him come over to me I have him tell
me what he did I explained to him how
that hurts people's feelings and he
doesn't like it when his feelings are
hurt so he needs to understand
think about it for a second you know in
the last time your heart hurt or you
didn't feel good you're making someone
feel that way when you do that and you
understand that and even if I get a
glimmer that he's even trying to
understand okay good you understand that
now what I need you to do is you need to
go over and you need to apologize to GD
which is we've got a call his
grandmother or summer my girlfriend or
whomever need to go over and apologize
to them you need to apologize them
specifically so I'm sorry I yelled or
I'm sorry I threw something or whatever
because he's a toddler and they do those
things and then when you do that you
come back come back over immediately
after you do it you come back to me and
then I say no thank you for doing that I
love you and I'm glad you understand now
even if he doesn't understand because
part of his brain is growing the I
understood that even if he doesn't now
how did you learn this did you meet him
to look he made it up okay I made it up
because I knew this how you were raised
no no I was left alone for big portions
of time to think about it but my mom was
always super supportive and my dad was a
get off your ass kind of a guy so they
were I got both sides but in not in one
person you know my dad's my dad had a
great thing like I had my problems in my
dad when I was growing up as all boys do
with their dad but there was one great
thing that he did that I thank him for
is he said will if you hurt yourself or
you're sick we'll take care of you but
no pity we're not gonna pity you we're
gonna heal you we're gonna take care of
you but we're not gonna feel bad with
you and I'm only no pity why not because
it doesn't help you get better I love
you but we're not gonna pity you okay is
happeh thee and pity are different yes
okay yeah we know we understand you're
hurt okay effing Lee they're gonna feel
it but we're not gonna get on a pity
parade with you and go hoos oh poor
little baby poor little baby okay and do
you do that with your kid um yeah but
i'm not i haven't set it up my dad was
maybe you know
I was probably 11 or 12 I mean he said
that overtly to me but I realized that's
how I'd been raised at that point and it
was really helpful probably okay it was
really like I don't pity myself when I'm
sick or ill or in a problem I just
get up and do it right or I
recognize that I'm incapable of fixing
it right now and just soldier it out
till I am but I don't feel bad for
myself I feel like that would help in
standup they asked you right yeah it
does already shitty gigs there's no bad
set there's no such thing as a shitty
gig well no I mean if it stand up is
stand up is learning to swim while
drowning okay it's if you look at it
from that perspective than they're all
shitty gigs because they all are until
you're at Olympic level and even then
you're like I've got the next meet oh my
god how am I going to keep this up but
whatever the the reality is is as a
stand-up you're learning from each of
these things it's your new even if
you're not consciously learning it your
nervous system is learning don't do that
again and as a comedian we're
massage therapists in the entertainment
world you know you can't massage their
bridges never go to a person laying on
the the I'm sorry I can't
massage your you're too tense it's not
the audience's fault man I got a
job to do ah no I know what you're
saying but there are also liked it don't
want to like it cuz it takes too much
responsibility no you're right I know
you're saying there are two different
camps though in in comedy where some
comedians not that is strong late week
well and important no go ahead yeah i
don't i don't like blaming the audience
either yeah but when I blame the quote
audience I don't think I'm blaming the
individual people sometimes I'm saying
the energy in here is just I
sorry but my job is energy yes as a
comedian sometimes don't you ever go
into a gig where and again this yeah you
Karen l17 this parallels even parenting
stuff uh-huh we just go in and you're
like oh
okay I see everything is stacked against
me I still have to persevere yeah even
though I'm in a ballroom where half the
audience is 500 feet away from me and
they're citing a terrible it might mean
yes absolutely eating dessert um someone
just came up and did a speech about you
know so-and-so the president who died
and now comedy so like the the
everything the universe inside of the
room is a swirling pile of feces and you
have to go in there and like you said I
get it that's a great analogy I have to
massage a person who's too tense they
need it more than anybody yes those
people need it more than anybody but
then you have the people that aren't
paying attention that are chatting their
backs or to you because they're sitting
at bar mitzvah tables which is what i
call the roundtables and a banquet hall
or whatever that and it's like how am I
supposed to work under these
circumstances you're supposed to
bulldoze well I do I personally do I
know some comics that are like this
and they hate it I personally do but
that's what I would call a shitty gig
like if you were to work that gig I
would not say oh who books that like I
wouldn't be like oh I want to do that
show I'd be like ooh keep me away well
there's I mean that's not a show that's
the venue that's what I'm saying like
sometimes it's not the individual people
metal bands shouldn't play high school
proms that's not there's nothing to do
with the prom or the band right that's
not a shitty gig that's a mismatch and a
mismatch is fine but don't do the
mismatch again and if you are gonna do
the mismatch again and go okay we need a
set that's for the Miss match we if
we're gonna play we're gonna be the
metal band that plays proms I see them
from set got it or don't do it right
that's it I mean it's simple turn it
down turn it down or be the one person
who can murder it yeah I mean I
I again that comes from you can be sick
and will heal you but we're no pity I
like that I kind of like that you know
it's it goes hand in hand with like when
your kid falls down you don't make a big
deal type of thing yeah like my kid
falls and I go oh I saw you fell down
the stairs
last night he was in the bathtub he
starts like he starts messing around he
loves to do this and now I'm gonna look
at it differently cuz you're right his
brain is jello yeah but he's um like
sipping the bathwater yeah yeah the
liquor ban I gonna go do just so you
know I mean you know make a choice but
just so you know Abe that's kind of
gross mm-hmm um it's not like gonna hurt
you per se cuz we use pretty crunchy
soap and stuff like that like it's not
chemical e but it's just like it's your
ass juice that you're sitting in you're
just sitting and asked juice drinking it
and I'll say that to him you know I mean
and and also it's not safe what you're
doing cuz he was kind of around
all of a sudden big huge gulp right in
his lungs yeah and he starts choking
yeah and he's coughing his face gets
super red I pull him out of the bathtub
which is so hard to do with this
big old belly when your thumb fast
sometimes and I pull him out and the
mixture he's okay and he's coughing he's
crying yeah he's freaking out the fear
in his eyes and I just kept really
common I go oh yeah yeah you choked huh
cuz you try to just I don't wanna make a
big deal but I was like just get it out
just go get it out get it out but like
make it solve it solve it yeah the other
thing too is you can't get too
emotionally involved in it because if
you looked panicked right then things
are really yes the ship is sinking right
it's one thing if I can't swim all the
sudden my parents have to pull me out of
the tub all right out of the pool or
whatever but if they're in the water
with me and they're like oh my god what
do we do right all of a sudden the ship
is going down total one trust point I
have which is you is freaking the
out nothing's okay yeah so I yeah I just
don't buy that uh like I I love him in
such a way that my skin burns if he
bumps his head you know what I mean like
I I feel yeah it's like the
Corsican brothers I feel it he does it
it just you know I used to have this
thing like I have the strongest stomach
in the world you can talk about anything
you want at lunch nothing grosses me out
you know the only thing that actually
grosses me out is an old man with a
bandaid on his head that's like a top of
bald head spotty head big scab
with a bandaid on top of it oh my god
yeah horrible yeah because there's only
two ways that happen oh there's only two
ways that happen and they both went it's
either grandpa or grandpa and he did
somebody's beating him or he walked his
self and I and both of them hurt me yeah
inside empathetically physically
whatever my son has the same kind of
reflex that I have but I've had to fight
that so much to make sure that he knows
yeah it's cool yeah yes and he's a tough
little now because of it you know
I mean like he's he's rambunctious he
likes to wrestle and they even say that
like you can judge a boy's uh grades in
second grade like the his grades will be
higher and you can tell more so by
whether or not he he was he does
horseplay at home versus his grades in
first grade horse places horse plays at
home as grades will be better because
there's a social dynamic and boys and
how they work out the energy that's in
them horseplay helps let me ask you a
question and my kid loves to do that
with my husband they wrestle and they do
all that stuff then all of a sudden he
hits a whiny point where either he's
starting to feel defeated mm-hmm and he
goes I don't like that cuz he's starting
to feel maybe like um you gotta let him
win is your husband just constantly
painting him and holding him down and me
oh it's pretty you're a loser you're a
loser you'll never take your old man did
he do that they know but he has a point
where he just like freaks out where he's
like no and then you're like oh well
this isn't fun now now you're just
whining so you gotta be you gotta back
off and play and you got it doing rounds
if you know he gets to that point you
got to stop the play before it ever gets
one yeah you got n distract but I think
he was really cause for patients you
just gotta the feline them
somewhere else they are my mom works my
mom was a nurse she worked in home
health services which is you know for
the state of Kentucky going to all these
places make sure they're not putting out
cigarettes and old people and
and take cash in their social security
checks like that and so there's a
lot of people with Alzheimer's and
dementia and that kind of stuff is the
exact same thing with a you know your
brain is jelly and then it goes to jelly
and in the middle you got a nice arc you
know I've always said that that that
life you start your life your
pants you end your life your
pants and in the middle you try to
mitigate the number of times you
your pants that's life so the the same
way you get an Alzheimer's person or a
person with dementia back on point and
focused and keep them from panicking or
going in a psychological circle is the
exact same thing you do with a toddler
and so if you know he has that limit if
you know he reaches that point and he's
like abort they wrestling early yeah you
know what I mean start getting out if
the first sign of it plate like another
toy or whatever like you know to almost
dinner time even if it's just take him
off the thing and he goes once to go
back to it right once he goes back to it
is brain hits a reset point and he'll be
playing again I try to do that I try to
go it's a water break you know I'm doing
before that though before yeah board
early that's what I would say get to get
him out early that way he'll never get
to that whatever the trigger point is
get out before the trigger point and
you'll have to watch to know what that
is but if you can play for 10-15 minutes
at eight minutes go all right you guys
settle down you know and you know right
right right and bring because I feel
like sometimes you know I have a
four-year-old and then I have a 40
something year old and I have to like
let the difference sometimes you know I
mean to be like sure you guys why like I
come in literally talking to my husband
and my four-year-old almost the same way
like guys why does it have to come to
this point mm-hmm you know and my
husband's like whoo he started it like
it's bad i can't answer that's all never
actually you like younger man just to a
but i think i don't know i think that's
interesting I'm gonna see what is what
my husband's test scores are um but is
it true do you believe this is kind of
going off point okay but um just cuz you
said second grade testing have you heard
this dealio the third grade testing that
they take the test scores that kids boys
and girls
going to assume put out in the third
grade to know what kind of jails they
should build 20 years from then have you
heard that theory I suppose but
understand that 20 years ago imagine
technology life and and the like 20
years ago you could make a living doing
apps you couldn't be a programmer which
would you know basically be Asperger's
in the late 80s yeah um the life
span of human beings in 20 years we've
gone from an expected 78 years old in
the United States to an expected 99 year
old oh jeez 20 years we will go from an
expected 99 to an expected 160 in the
next 20 come on dead serious no that's
here there's no way there's total way as
a matter of fact that's low um so
they're gonna have like 80 year fixed
mortgages no no money's going away money
is good that's that'll be right that's
about 60 to 80 years away what do you
mean money is going away um once you
move away from a resource-based economy
um which is what we are now oil gold get
you know gas coal that kind of stuff
water to some degree once you move past
a permanent resource-based economy where
you have hubs of money like I'm sitting
on oil you need it I'm sitting on coal
you need it right once we move away from
that permanently which we are doing to a
more like kind of Elon Musk Tesla Google
Apple kind of way where you know your
baselines are covered on a sociological
level Star Trek style if you want to
make money to buy stuff later you can
and everybody else just kind of has a
baseline existence which is where we're
headed like it or not that's what's
going to happen you shift into a
different psychological makeup as well I
happen to think there are no adults on
the planet but I think human beings
never reach adulthood before we die I
think 80 year old is still a child in
human mentality and that are you
pitching me a movie right no no and that
well like I do I'm doing a show this
year for the Sens foundation which are
the thousand year lifespan people and
then
a they they've been working with you
know they know the guy like Ray Kurzweil
it at Google and all the AI people and
stuff and they're looking at a legit
thousand year lifespan for the four
humans within a couple hundred years and
raising the human lifespan a couple
hundred years in the next 50 mainly
because a lot of them want to be around
to see it and what's happening is
Moore's law and stop me if I'm getting
too technical Moore's law which is
attributed to technology meaning that
every 18 months computer chips get get
half as expensive and twice as fast and
half in size right which has been
happening since the late 60s is now
attributing to biology and so cancer
cures and that kind of stuff will reach
a critical mass where most disease and
aging being one of them will be cured
effectively in an ARCA within our
possible lifetime so their theory and
this stands mechanically is that the
first person lived to be 250 years old
is live right now it's probably a girl
and she's probably 15 years old and the
first person led to be a thousand years
old is only ten years younger than she
is and so we have no idea what 20 years
from now life will be like because if
you think of pre iPhone and whatever
think of pre Instagram and Twitter and
how we're socially interacting yeah Elon
Musk says we're actually growing a
nervous system as a society through the
internet that that's what the internet
is our society is becoming an organism
in and of itself and it's gone from the
single-celled organism you know
disconnected human being speaking one on
one used to only be able to communicate
cell to cell one person talking to
another person then we got phones which
was a rudimentary way of limited
communication which is cell lines now we
can communicate pictures and thoughts
blogging and ideas we're not that far
away from we've now they can record
dreams which means consciousness you'll
be able to send your dreams or if you
were thinking about someone you love you
can send them the thought you had if you
want
um that's coming let's don't I'm not
even making it up or even saying it
might or science fiction says that but
it's coming and therefore you can't wrap
your head around you can't tell what a
third-grader today's world is going to
be like in 15 years much less tengo
watch the like Microsoft has put out
these hollow glasses which are like
Google glass on steroids that you wear
around your home whatever they can
project stuff onto flat surfaces and you
can hologram people in your environment
whatever those are going to be contacts
in 10 years like understand you don't
know the world your child is going to
grow into so adaptability is the only
skill that you can actually give them
that's worth a because it's not
saying you need to know this isn't true
because everything you need to know is
becoming partially obsolete except for
personal resilience adaptability
strength of character those kind of
things those are the only things you put
in anything mechanical you it's
that's gone oh my god you can't say a
third grader whose weird or or mentally
off one particular who hates Authority
or something like that where it's gonna
end up in jail cuz Elon Musk
AIDS Authority the president every pray
that we have hates Authority that's why
they become the authority you can't
become a leader without despising
authority because you would never let
anybody be above you the leader needs to
be the one on top right and so to be a
leader you have to hate the idea of a
priority right right level 8 stand-ups
we all hate Authority oh yeah and you
Martin does it third grade there's no
way I'd look like a guy who's in
three unions has four jobs at any given
time and as a quality father you know
what I mean you couldn't judge from me
at third grade and Peaks mill Kentucky
and who just used his thoughts to pull
one of his balls out yeah right actually
you've been doing that yeah yeah I
haven't try nieces I'm judged so hard
see ya are you other than that I have no
opinion after me the name my next
special other than that I have no
opinion yeah holy you don't know
can we can I move in with you yeah yeah
I'm gonna start a commune I think I
should start my own church should search
of the elevated mind or something it's
like it you know it's like Joe Rogan's
world but without the DMT and ass but
you'd still have those floating tanks
cuz those I heard her pretty kicker Oh
sensory deprivation to yeah sure okay
let me just end on this cuz I know you
probably have to go cuz you have four
jobs at any time yeah yeah um uh are you
also like cuz all of that is
mind-blowing awesome i love that kind of
style me too i love it's what I my goal
and now and my stand-up is to start
parking lot conversations you know you
ever get caught watch a movie or
something or go to a lecture right we
have a college class or whatever and you
end up leaning against the car talking
till three o'clock and having yeah
that's what I want can I tell you the
last time i did it it's been a while
since i did that last time i did that
was um at the arclight mm-hmm after
fahrenheit 911 sure okay yeah uh that's
the last time I haven't haven't done I
love those I have him all the time but I
instigate them haha I usually the person
that people are hanging around to talk
about right cuz i love that kind of
conversation but but the reason i
thought of it what really clicked was a
movie called mind walk uh-huh ever seen
that movie sam waterston and john hurt
and i forget the the actress in it with
them because she's a french actress and
I know her name in the first place when
the movie came out but it's it's like my
dinner with Andre kind of style movie
it's three people a poet an
astrophysicist and a politician walking
around mulsanne michel in france which
is this castle that every day the tide
comes up makes it an island and every
day the tide goes down and you can walk
you can drive the road in and out of it
and they're talking about systems
thinking and how we need a shift in
paradigm from Cartesian dualism and you
know which is the idea that everything
has parts and you can take those parts
apart and put another part in and it's
fine to systems thinking that everything
is connected somehow and it was
fascinating and I afterwards I walked
out of the theater feeling like my head
was
so big wouldn't fit out of the door and
I ended up having this conversation with
the people I was there with we were
literally leaning against our car and it
was three o'clock in the morning and I
was like this is awesome yeah if I could
do this with my stand-up I would have
really achieved something it's hard to
make a dick joke about shifting the
paradigm I don't think so I think you
could do it pregnant lady yeah female of
the species I am of which it there's a
you know a narrow field as far as stand
up schoo although increasingly it's
ironic that in the in the minority and
gender sensitive aspect of the Arts
which we very much are and I I think
that's one of the wonderful things about
the Arts is that we overdo it sometimes
and you have like it literally I think
it's like whatever thirteen percent of
the populace is asian-american and fifty
percent of nightly newscasts or there's
an Asian person as the co-host some
nonsense is like a forty-two percent or
something like large number like half of
your nightly news teams having an Asian
co-host as if it's referential to who's
watching right manage so isn't you know
I mean but it's how that's why by the
way that's why redneck white people
you're like why the are they
freaking out why they feel like there's
only fifteen percent of the country's
black yeah only 12 person why they feel
like they're surrounded cuz when they
turn on the nightly news and the weather
guy is black and then and fifty percent
of the news team is Asian they're like
where did we stop being people run and
everything everybody here's why why why
is the local TV station representative
of you know more diverse than their
reality and they freaked out because of
that yeah and and the same you know
there's a manou we don't need a white
male comedian night at by any stretch of
the imagination but there is an element
of percentage of female comedians
specifically is it's very narrow it's
very few mm-hmm so when you have a all
female comics night a lot of the like
male comments are like we
not realizing they have their own night
all the time Friday night right my kid
will ask me if I was the only girl if I
could like the next day how was your
show last night mommy and I was like I
was great and he was like we were you
the only girl he'll ask me that and if I
went up last I don't know why he puts
like didn't want you to be the headliner
you know but for him cuz hes for going
last is bad oh right yeah being picked
last right exactly and I don't know tell
me last tonight yeah that's yo yeah I
went last I headlined I don't think I go
last knows it go in the middle sometimes
I'm a woman since I'm not whatever its
fluid is it well you know I'm trying to
fit in sure right if it's a shitty room
I try to I pull my out a couple
times that's why they do it yes yeah no
I don't know um god damn it Hal sparks I
know it's so much to talk to murder
great I know god damn it you're great
it's saying here's the thing it's not
it's not first of all it's not an
accident but also it's not inborn not
special because of anything in you know
any genetic aspect certainly not but
there are interesting things that you're
passionate about that that's what I just
tell people I just so you know what find
someone my friend is single right now
she's like I can't find go just find
someone who is interesting and is
passionate about something and that
that's that's hard though but that's
hard it is but I think it's hard because
of the people that they are surrounding
themselves with but I go to bars well we
hire you what well I don't why are you
going to a bar yeah I don't drink fine
someone I don't go a drink in my life no
come on never never won not a one
whatever nyquil that's true I'm true no
true nothing no no drugs are you crunchy
also cuz I i don't know if that goes
hand in hand with being um you know
progressive liberal well Maclagan right
now that's 50 inches i've been vegan
since january because I'm lift I'm
putting on muscle right I decided to do
it in a way that I didn't want I wanted
to put on muscle without getting fat so
ways to do it was um you know vegans a
good way to do that a vegan protein
instead of fun yeah and right got it and
no animal products to make you kind of
swollen puffy and
you buy like you know like more you know
whole foods type of sure okay well I
mean that's sweet i don't hide the fuel
that's going into your body is the one
thing you right in control and what
about your kid like are you raising him
a little bit more crunchy know my um
like organic it's a war him yeah i do do
organic food for him I get most of my
stuff in whole foods or I'll take them
to places like lemonade and rice is
where he can start picking stuff that's
the better version of what he wants
right wants pizza but you know anyone's
and and at this point he was having uh
it is a long story but he was having
trouble gaining weight at one point and
so I to me all bets were off until you
stabilize and you get to a point where
your weight is you know strong if you're
gonna eat whatever will go and your free
college sort of junk food I'm not taking
you know McDonald's not giving you soda
cuz sugar and all the sugar that's in
that food will crank up your metabolism
anyways you'll just turn whatever you're
eating to ash and it won't become muscle
and fat and skin and yeah nails and hair
and whatever and um so I started you
know doubling him up on caloric intake
that kind of stuff so I didn't have a
problem with him consuming meat and
dairy if he would take it in and I I
also that again you're not dealing with
an adult so you have to deal with the
you know the ethical dietary choices
your kid has to make on their own it's
right right um and you could introduce
them to that you know because he didn't
understand its recent just recently he
asked about where cheese comes from for
example and I said well Jesus is an aged
storm of milk it take milk and they
process it and enzymes to it and
eventually it will grow into into cheese
it's a byproduct it's not you know
something that is not a cheese tree it
doesn't come up you know and we joked
about the cheese treat for about a week
his brain is starting to move into that
where does stuff come from where I stuff
go yeah thing um and so will we know
will but we're very specific in our
family my dad's an architect moms as a
nurse we're honest about stuff yeah you
know um I don't have a problem with
Santa Claus and Tooth Fairy and all that
kind of stuff for a while cuz it's fun
when you're a kid right but then yeah
one day you'll know when she rushes
trips yeah yeah
yeah uh you're crushing my dreams
because we have to go we're so over
I'm so sorry oh did I are you no no I
right I believe me I went whenever
there's a situation where I'm allowed to
talk I block out a lot of time I just
love it mm-hmm I love it thank you so
much yeah my pleasure into the podcast
or can you help me find you at house
marks on Twitter my my you tube is uh
five park five nations it's just sparks
with five instead of s's okay um all
those links are on my if you follow me
on twitter you'll see all that stuff pop
up my facebook page is the house barks
fang page cuz i have kind of sharp teeth
um that's where that came from uh and
then you know how sparks calm is my
website although that's going through a
revamp because i'm going i'm gonna start
doing that the grid that new AI website
thing that's coming up its supposed to
work really cool so we'll see that makes
you live to a thousand no that's
different that's different okay but yeah
that I mean that's a whole other
conversation if we live to 250 can we
promise to hang out yeah in our 200 for
it oh that's the sweetest thing yeah
thank you so much yeah interesting we
will be at that point I hope or just
robots will be just half robotic
there'll be a version of you that might
be a robot yeah i'll leave you with this
this is this you can think about um
first of all will never send people in
the deep space because why bother you'll
send downloaded consciousness from human
beings that are alive now you'll
download it into a computer's mainframe
instead of having AI you'll have your
brain inside a computer you know inside
a robot fixture that'll be very
organic-looking and very humanoid but
not actually be a person person that can
be damaged the same way the animals you
know stay in stasis for a long time so a
version of your consciousness will reach
a far-off galaxy 20,000 years from now
land on a planet have its own life and
do its own thing based on what you want
to discover based on the intellect you
had when it left that being said if you
were to travel let's say to the nearest
livable planet which science has
discovered the 148th in the last six
months
there's eight there's potential eight
point two billion livable planets in our
in our universe um in our galaxy alone
much less the universe just our galaxy
eight point two billion possible livable
planets okay mathematically it's
impossible there is in life impossible
right just get used to that idea to at
least basic cable yeah yeah yeah they
have bases there's amish on another
planet that we could totally with
yes we could be the aliens anally probe
them wouldn't that be ah so uh you get
your ship and you want to go to one of
those places okay you're gonna live 500
years how many movies and video
games can you play on route before you
go and how long can you stay in a dream
state and a stasis to before you went
completely insane probably not long
because the human brain is pretty
complex you couldn't you could sleep for
60 years you'd have to get up
and do something right yeah your body's
got to move around or do something every
so often or at least think it is to keep
it sells going your brain can't tell the
difference between real and something
imagined same muscles fire if you have a
dream you just have a chemical in your
body that keeps you from punching
yourself in the face that's why you feel
like you're walking in marshmallow when
you're running in a dream is because
your character and your dream is running
but your body is telling your real
muscles to knock it the off so you
don't kill yourself that's why it feels
like marshmallow why can't I run that's
what that's from so you're in a dream
state traveling to another planet you
have 500 years to get there you could
watch the movies you could play some
games but you need something that was
longer right to keep yourself busy
occupied psychologically so you wouldn't
go nuts at that point technology will be
advanced enough where you can download
consciousness from people who either are
alive or are have passed so somebody
goes when they die I know they're going
to die the last thing you would go is go
to this church like experience where you
upload your consciousness into this big
mainframe or into the cloud or into a
robot or into whatever housing they're
going to put them in this is not an if
this is a win so you're traveling in
space you could take any of these lives
any of them and download them into your
brain so you would
live this life out 80 years while you're
in stasis the life of a you know and you
might have be able to get race memory
meaning you can get the memories of your
grandfather out of your cells so you
could know what it was like to live in
the 1800s of the sixteen hundreds or
whatever going back deep enough so
you're laying in this stasis tube and
you're on your way to a planet and your
and you go maybe four or five lifetimes
in normal human years that you'd be
downloading a hundred years as this
person 80 years as this person may be 20
years is another person who was a
military vet or something like that and
you died and you experience that and
then you wake up for a little while take
stretch your legs in the ship go back
pick another one get back in there is no
way scientifically to prove that's not
happening to you right now that you
aren't really already in that spaceship
tube re living the life of me or you
what if I just pulled my face off right
now then that would have had to been
something so that person did or see it's
not gonna be recording like a movie not
gonna be their exact life it'll probably
be like a video game where you'll have
variety and that's why you have options
in your life and you can make it into
whatever you want I just remove my whole
face like a fembot yeah the first
pregnant fembot Hey yeah that's true
there's an N scientist says is
discovered that if you look up the
holographic universe of potential that
we are living in a hologram which is
entirely possible well I knew you were
gonna say that because I had already
downloaded your consciousness right I
knew you're gonna ask that uh-huh and I
want to go live on your commune it'll be
so fun I don't want that's true there's
no way to prove that you're not living a
recording of some of this person's life
let's start a house parks comeon page
and we're all gonna join in on what's
drop loads of wisdom oh you're gonna
drop loads oh yeah make mine my own Jim
Jones babies holy yeah there's no
way to prove that you're you I mean but
I I have uh no nope but I got the thing
went to the DMV no but they I peed in a
cup no no
still doesn't prove it it's all a big
hologram cutting through baking and now
I know why you don't put cream in your
coffee it all came around yeah yeah I
don't do i add this my the drinking and
this is true the drinking one of the
things that you can extend your life
with his caloric restriction I'm having
too many calories and since I'm trying
to put on weight I can't exactly drop my
calories down so one of the ways you do
that is through intermittent fasting
uh-huh people want to look that up they
can but it's you don't eat the first six
hours you're up why do many calories the
first six hours you're up you don't eat
and so you don't you either you know you
can take supplements but you know
calories so water and black coffees one
of the ways cuz it's an appetite
suppressant slightly so we go all right
well I'm gonna take a nap yeah after all
of this information i feel like i just
downloaded you hmm yeah Wow house barks
let's put our nipples together and hug I
want to say thank you and I appreciate
it grab me on and allowing me to speak
freely uh yeah and I'm gonna just bring
my kid over to you yeah how old is your
he's four-and-a-half perfect let's have
a play date and I'm just gonna let I'm
just gonna let you figure it out yeah
and I'll watch dates and then i'll just
take notes on how not to lose his mind
when doesn't put his shoes on our kids
are when they're rough housing and your
kid starts to be a whiny little
yeah my kids will go with the the
matter with you right he'll he'll say
cowboy the up yeah don't toddler
see Zack up yeah yeah okay got it and
huh yeah and then the Soviet will come
out in my kid I literally taught my kid
to say get up sucka when he knocks me
down and I fall on the ground he stands
over me he goes get up sucka and I told
my kid um about nickels and how they
ruin everything Yeah right he's a nickel
we don't talk to him Mikey Flynn yeah
Michael are you still awake yeah me oh
hey what do you been doing back there um
I'm enjoying the show I'm I was really i
love this episode i love what house
talking about all the future stuff
mm-hmm but you don't want to show your
face emeritus
there it is Mikey flame for everyone
that knows sits behind a cubicle and
like like gay with what's the animal
that pops her head up and meerkat well I
kind of like a meerkat I guess looking
for a falcon yeah a hedge no not a
hedgehog not our daughters gopher yeah
no damn alright no nobody um how sparks
get out of here okay bye okay bye so
that was Hal right and I still didn't
want it to end and III think we could
have gone on for another hour and a half
easily easily I had so many more
questions god damn it but you can still
find him and you can still connect with
him on the twitter at hal sparks HAL
sparks and of course he has a YouTube
page and you can find him on facebook he
has a fang page that what he called it a
fan page uh he's great and you know what
we do set list together a lot so look
for him on that show cuz that is um a
really fun improv show that's all off
top of your head and where am I gonna be
well I'm gonna be doing stuff look just
cuz this belly's getting bigger does not
mean that I'm stuck on the couch what
I'd love to be but I gotta keep movin
and shakin so check your comedy calm i
know i have to update it but i do have
spots coming up i am going to be doing a
lot of set list because i just shot my
special so I kind of don't want to do my
material at all and I'm in the middle of
writing new stuff so it's like this this
no-man's land that I'm living in right
now so um come out too let's see when is
this going to come out nerdmelt nerdmelt
jun 27th I think this might come out
before then maybe if not you missed an
amazing set list show at at the meltdown
theatre I'm doing that I'm gonna be
doing I'm doing shows in July even
though i'm doing july i'm still gonna do
shows so come out to the hollywood
improv July tenth
for another set list show and I'm around
so come find me you know until I push
this human out of me I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be movin and shakin so connect
with me on the twitter at kira comedy
connect with all things comedy on the
twitter sitting right now in the very
perfectly air-conditioned studio with
mikey Flynn what's your twitter Mike oh
I'm real Mike Flynn the real Mike Flynn
yeah are there some fake ones I think so
there's lots of us out there Irish
really that doesn't seem like a common
name at all they're all cousins it's
fine considering my my mic is Mike Finn
Finnegan uh yeah please the real Mike
fan guys don't don't um don't follow
those posers by the way Michael I i
found a fake facebook page under my name
this is like the third or fourth why
would anyone why do they care to start a
fake facebook page of me right tom see
what's up so I try to add myself yeah
there you go seems a little masturbatory
and try to click on myself over and over
again but come find me and come at us
and go to my facebook page for the
podcast which is the kira soltanovich
show and I
I don't know what's gonna happen when I
do have this kid I'm just giving
everyone a heads up on episodes so bear
with me I might do just some solo shows
we'll see i might have to start doing
some from the house I don't know we're
gonna play it by ear but just giving
everyone a heads up on on what's
happening with the podcast thanks for
listening thanks for giving us stars on
iTunes thanks for being great fans and
you know what go real issen right now
you just listen to how sparks go back
again you missed some stuff go right now
okay fight
you